[Music]
hi I'm loss of Mandvi and these are the
10 essential things I can't live without
[Music]
hi Louie now a lot of you people are
there saying what is a loogie
it's say Indian dress you basically step
inside it like this and then you take it
from here and it's kind of like a diaper
the beauty of this is you wear this
completely naked you might think this is
weird but it's a it's a headshot of
Samantha bee she doesn't know that I
have a headshot of her it was given to
me by her husband Jason Jones
I was said do you have a small framed
picture of my wife and I said no and he
was like listen seriously I want you to
have this my collection of Nicholas
Sparks books that's right
I saw the movie The Notebook I bawled my
eyes out and then I have to go out and
buy the books I read them pretty much on
a regular basis sometimes I'll just
close my eyes pick one and just start
reading it it's hard to read with your
eyes closed eventually after open my
eyes I'm not going to talk a lot about
them because I get very evil klimt right
it's a little post-colonial but it is
Javier my personal valet Javier come
here there he is
say hi to the people hi people sit down
yeah there you go
no a little bit higher back up back up
back up
that's it Javier what do you are you
Mexican Asian sir Asian [ __ ] up name
is Javier for an Asian once you button
up there look a sharp well yeah just
yeah is that okay you know what forget
it it looks disgusting when you do that
just sit down lose some weight
Oh Javier thank you no I didn't tell you
didn't need to get up okay when I say
get up that's when you get up that's how
it works I'm
boss okay you not the boss say goodbye
to the people goodbye people people
thank you bye bye
get up get up go bye get me a cab
everybody should have this the Omni
blend it comes a little like a dildo I
don't know why we have that you take
some spinach celery some carrots oh and
some OJ Xavier give me the [ __ ] I
told you that when the OJ thank you get
out
so puts the PO J in there put it on high
it's healthy Jesus that is [ __ ]
disgusting yeah I drink this so that's
it
those are my essentials follow us at
hashtag G key ten and you can follow me
on Twitter at awesome if you like this
video comment if you didn't like the
video [ __ ] you Xavier
[Music]